qu'ils se rendent compte qu au fur et à
mesure du tournage que certains couples
ne soit échangiste et c'est pour ça
qu'il participe à l'émission à savoir
non mais a depuis changé des biens
sociaux
oui monsieur oui
oui parce que j'ai changé ma maison avec
quelqu'un chez le notaire je vous
promets quand on passe chez le notaire
qu'on échange sa maison avec quelqu'un
on est entre les échangistes monsieur
machin mais le harbin dit oui a ajouté
la grisonne bits
[Applaudissements]
choquée j'ai une petite info que des
succès était un saut spécial et avec des
échangistes et voulait même changer nos
en bienvenue en nous pour ça